let's cross over ball knocked loose who
are too hard
Williams shaken up Durant drives layup
it's good
Thompson comes crashing into Beverly
here's the end of the play
[Music]
we'll take a timeout warriors up a dozen
that commercial break change the right
shoe so now he's wearing two separate
shoes exclamation point
put the defense in an emphatic jab shoot
over 40% around 40% of three-pointers
you just got to let it fly and live with
the results 321 of the second quarter in
Game one this is LA Clippers team was
outscored five years and they have been
brilliant here at beautiful power for
the Clippers to Michael Green who dish
have checked in that sense to rant
trouble on and if you look at the body
language you would think that the
Warriors are trying to get back in this
game
doctors three to go before Durant played
by he'll go ran on a crossover for Kevin
Durant sit all three of the shots there
I got a piece with six on the shot clock
Wow tough turnaround to KD and again you
watch this basket he gets his flaps out
of his hand turn around
fadeaway shamon is an excellent
three-point shooter big missed that time
to read goes to rats scores and one for
Katie
by the way Durant's 27 in the first half
matched a playoff career-high
another bounding and so they're gonna
miss uh bookie cousins but they they can
make up for it with with the depth of
their team and Katie pulls out Wow
drops another three on yeah Wow they
match up with Milwaukee who has home
court all the way through the bucks at
the best record means killed Jess
Alexander at the rim a rejection for
Katie gets to this ball I mean he just
gets up there and no way was that gonna
be able to go in over KD we objected to
the golf melon re now on Durant five to
shoot Durant's little crossover pull-up
shot
that's good no he's still able to finish
in traffic that was an impressive shot
Durant
foul and one and the crowd feeling the
same way they thought there were plenty
of contact at one but not at this end
[Applause]
Durant long three cabinet and the foul
Kevin Durant with a chance for a
four-point play from several feet beyond
the arc now and already this his second
foul and his clearly contact
Durant 18 points five rebounds backdoor
curry inside pass Durant
pulled a flush the missing that shot he
needs to continue to keep on being
aggressive this back to the lab was to
the crossover
[Applause]
out of it a long time to go with the
Clippers Lou Williams they're spinning
themselves right now just a bad miss but
it could open look for Lou Williams just
coming on
[Applause]
the land was offered yes
[Applause]
all right Thank You Kristen the cloud
was in it for a while
[Applause]
soomi the pool
Williams is all toxin
the best in the business this team when
it comes to the break I don't know what
even though after rent jump but I know
he dunked that in
[Applause]
[Music]
yes and the foul
[Applause]
from downtown
KD again how does he find this angle I
don't know move out the way get dunked
on Lou Williams allowing the to demand o
blocked by Thompson the demand with Lou
Williams and Harrell coming into the
game and Durant racing down a floor on
another pretty fee from draymond Green
temple is gone and Durant right now
[Music]
[Applause]
Durant turn spires counted along clock
winding down turn temple tries to
contest the old Shane Battier in the
face hits him down low and draymond
Green finds Duran Duran straight on 3x
good the best play of the Warriors do a
great job will one a guy has it going
[Applause]
Durant find some room but sit in Kevin
Durant 31 points yeah Nazareth education
but you're right
Durant what's the past draymond Green
the layup beautiful feed from Kevin
Durant good opportunity for Durant
go two for one try to get a quick shot
up Iran does three-pointer free throws
you knew it was coming
Kitson three-point line there's the
double on Durant back to draymond Green
Durant catches fires three pointer putts
it in Kevin Durant with 44 to see from
regular season but playoff matchups as
well curry class inside the green shot
clock winding down
Durant got Kevin Durant coming off that
50 point masterpiece on Game six against
the Clippers knocks it down and Jolin
State leads and he'd been shooting
really well late in the season and 49%
the first round
Durant to the basket has not seemed to
be bothering them one point games Mars
nice little fake guess pass to get a
love scoop blocked by Durant
Perry Thompson for three
warriors plus eight on the boards Durant
gets a running start and side
[Applause]
Green having another one of those visits
dream on dream games just like he did
game six Fridays Chris Paul can hit
here's Durant Koran drives and finishes
let go to him he's got house on him step
down as good step Ella inside it zip on
$0.25 over so far for the Warriors -
take it in we checked in with that crate
to punch a play by Giovanni point at the
offensive in but defensively against
this warrior team you need another guy
that can score to Rock but you got to
respect their an boy they're getting
wide open looks and the bucket with
layups and dunks I'm not gonna let you
play 101 and Golden State retakes the
lead
he's got 39 was those Lisa Salters
reported at the top of the telecast the
doctor couldn't believe he played with
it Duran the Euro step Tucker trying to
stay will endure him just too good and
it's back to one Durant has 41 and
Gordon
intercepted by two ran late past three
and two here comes three my behind the
back curry in the corner step back look
at only one reason and that is so Andre
Iguodala king guard James he was
brilliant out there on the court
everybody knows how difficult he is to
guard and I asked Andre I said how do
you feel and he said I feel old we said
the forty six point game on Saturday
tries on cappella twisting in a good
feed Looney cutting off the baseline but
enough help us play there by KD Harden
is the number one driver in the playoffs
the number one driver in the regular
season in the NBA turns beautiful shot
on the fly in the three previous to the
three previous games of this series in
the food and typically over these
championship years
here we go zhong huge iran with a three
to start this third quarter
it's falling towards
20 looking lost the ball steal by Kevin
ahead to Thompson in the hood another
one we found movie
turan's that's their second turnover
Leonard to see Jakob I think Durant got
a piece of that as siakam couldn't
complete the bass break was just 1 of 5
from three-point range
Dolan's state six of nine Durant fresh
free Kevin Durant his third
three-pointer already